(applause)
- So your new Netflix
movie is called Horse Girl,
so is it about a horse and a girl,
or why is it called that?
- It is about a girl
who used to ride horses,
and she no longer really does.
But she continues to have
a current obsession with her horse.
I wouldn't say that's the main...
That's sort of information
about her character.
It's really about a
socially isolated woman,
played by me, who begins
to have a series of
surreal dreams and starts
to lose her grip on reality.
- Yeah, I'd say so from that clip.
- Yeah!
(both laughing)
- The best part is Molly
Shannon's character
going, "Mmm, No.".
- I don't believe in that.
- I do not.
But do you believe in UFO's
or aliens and all that.
- Absolutely!
- Okay, I believe that
anything could exist.
I don't know.
- Well the universe does seem so big.
- Vast.
- Like unimaginably vast.
So also as we were writing this movie,
because I co-wrote it
with my friend Jeff Baena.
- [Kelly] So cool.
- Thank you.
First time.
- Go ahead.
Take all the jobs.
- Thanks everyone.
(laughter)
(applause)
For the support.
- I felt it here.
- I can tell you felt it.
- I love you!
- But as we were doing
research we read a lot of
message boards about
people being abducted,
or people who feel that
they've been abducted,
and actually there's
a lot of through lines
to those stories that
we wrote into the movie.
- Wow.
- Also my whole life,
I mean when I was in middle school,
my mom had this boyfriend who
was really into alien stuff.
We watched a lot of "X-Files"
and stuff like that.
- Yeah, Scully, Mulder, yes.
- Of course.
- I know them all.
- And he definitely told a story to me
that stuck with me for so
long about his encounter
with aliens where he was driving,
maybe through New Mexico,
and it was just desert,
and there were lights behind
him, he thought it was
a big truck, but then it
came up, went over his car.
Then he pulled over at his
next stop, it was a diner,
and he was eating a
burger and the burger chef
had the longest fingers he'd ever seen.
- That's not real, he made
that up to scare you, right?
- As I'm saying it,
it does sound like he probably
made it up to scare me,
but my whole life I've just
thought it was real, so.
- I would say I'm not into that at all.
- No
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Alison] I like regular size.
But if you like it, way to go.
(clapping)
- Yeah!
- So you are so great in
"Glow", and now I hear
there's another season, right?
- Yes, we're doing our
fourth and final season.
- That's exciting, have
you had such a great time?
(cheering and applauding)
- [Alison] Thank you.
- Because I hear that you've
just had the best time
with all the female... it's a female cast
and you'd think that
could get a little dicey.
- Oh my God.
- But it was so good.
- With a cast of 15 women it is
the least dramatic thing
I've ever worked on.
- [Kelly] That's awesome.
- And it's the greatest job of my life.
I love it, we get to do everything on it.
You know, we get to do dramatic scenes,
we get to do really broad comedy,
we get to do stuff that's
really physical in the ring.
Learning how to wrestle changed the way
that I relate to my body,
it's been really empowering,
and it's just fun, it's just really fun.
I love everyone, Betty Gilpin
has become my best friend.
I feel like sometimes
I think the only point
of the show was to bring her
as a soulmate into my life.
- I think that that does
happen, I think that we do go
through different paths and
it's just to meet these people,
and then you go onto something,
I believe that's true.
That's so cool though,
'cause I think you should
love where you work.
- Oh my God.
- You should love all the
people you're working with.
- It is the best.
(applauding)
- It's like the life lesson
I learned as I get older.
This is my favorite thing
I've found out about you,
is you know how to make balloon animals.
- Oh, yes!
- So, why?
(laughing)
- Well because I worked
for a summer as a clown
for children's birthday parties...
- I love this story!
- [Alison] You know.
As you do.
- So how did that come about,
you were like, "I'm just
gonna start being a clown."?
- Well it was right after high school,
or maybe in between my
junior and senior year
and I had a couple friends
from high school drama,
who were like, "oh, we got
this great job for the summer
"being clowns, you should do it.
"It's super easy and fun.",
and the offices were actually in Compton,
we had a big warehouse where we learned
how to make balloon animals, paint faces,
and do a few party games with the kids,
and we came with a
duffel bag and a boombox.
So I would drive to this
building in Compton,
do my clown makeup,
I wore a big yellow afro.
- [Kelly] I love this.
My clown name was Sunny.
(laughing)
And then I would drive all over
L.A. to all different types.
Parties in tiny apartments,
parties in big beautiful mansions,
and I would just come in by myself,
put some music on for an hour or two,
paint their faces, make balloon animals.
- That would make me so nervous,
'cause kids are not the
nicest all the time.
- Terrifying, terrifying.
To this day I think it might...
- They can be bullies!
- have been the best training
for my career as an actor.
- You're right.
- To be fearless, and to really
entertain a crowd of people.
- And to know that no
matter how hard you try,
you're still gonna suck to someone.
(audience laughing)
- I mean, you haven't seen
my clown work yet Kelly.
(laughing)
- Pretty outstanding.
I think this would be very
impressive for my kids,
can you teach me how to
make an animal balloon?
I wanna do that.
- I definitely can.
- Okay, okay, all right.
(laughing)
(audience applauding)
So wait, okay you want teal?
- Yes I do want teal.
- I'm gonna go red,
'cause I'm daring.
- Okay, so the important
thing is that first of all,
when you blow it up you always
wanna leave a little room,
because you gotta fill out the room.
We're gonna start at the
other end of the balloon.
- Oh 'cause when you blow
it up the air gets pushed.
- Exactly
- Nice, displacement, okay.
- We're gonna make just a
standard, four-legged animal,
which is a good base zone,
'cause then you can
always elongate the neck,
it's a giraffe.
Shorten everything, it's a poodle.
- Yes!
- We're gonna twist the
balloon into three circles.
So you're gonna do one, just twist it.
- I'm just afraid...
- Don't be scared.
- It's gonna pop, it's totally fine.
And then you, oh!
- And you're gonna hold onto it,
and then you're gonna do a second circle.
- How much do I have to
twist it for it to stay?
- Just a few times.
(audience laughing)
And then you're gonna twist
the third time around.
Kelly!
- I can't even get...
- Twist and hold, you
have to twist and hold.
Don't be afraid of the balloon.
- No, I'm not, I'm holding.
- Now hold.
- Hold.
- Now twist this section.
- Oh, oh you do, okay.
- Good, good.
- Okay.
- I've never taught this
before, it's my clown college.
- Okay.
And now fold it here
and twist that into that.
- That into that.
- It seems scary.
- And these don't pop?
Are you serious?
- You can still do it!
You can still do it!
- I'm about to have
a fight with you!
- You can still do it,
you can still do it,
you can still do it!
- Okay wait, so then you take that...
- Into that, go, go, go, go.
You can do it, it's not gonna pop.
It's not gonna pop.
(balloon squeaking)
Don't fear the balloon, great!
Great, okay great!
So now you have to...
- Yes!
(audience cheering)
I did it!
- I feel like it's a head on a stick.
- Looks like this, what do you do next?
- So then you do that a few more times.
So you make a little neck,
and then you do... right.
So you twist,
- [Both] then twist again.
- [Alison] Then you're gonna fold.
- [Kelly] You do it again.
- [Alison] Again.
- I'm gonna move forward
but I'm gonna double back.
- You go ahead.
- I'm gonna double back...
- We're gonna be here for
the length of a movie.
- And help so then you
do that a few more times.
- [Kelly] Like this?
- [Alison] Yes, yes, yes.
- Just do that? Okay.
- Do it, do it, do it.
I just like to encourage more than teach.
And then you do it again.
- Oh, do it again.
- And next thing you know,
you have a little dog.
- Wait, wait, so you do it again?
- Do it again.
- And then one more time, no wait,
you have to do another leg.
- Another leg, we're gonna edit this.
- This is great.
- It's gonna be great.
- You're gonna do it one more time.
Holy word I can't say on daytime.
(audience laughing)
- Here, wait, you know what you can do?
Just fold it and twist it in this.
Yes, yes.
- Yeah, like that?
And then what?
- No, no.
'Cause you're gonna kill his body.
You have to twist this way.
- I don't wanna kill his body.
- Into here.
- Okay, okay.
- And then do that.
- And then you twist this?
- And that's the last one.
- Okay.
(balloon squeaking)
- Yes, yes, you're doing it!
- Okay, okay.
- Wait, well...
- What?
- Oh yeah, that's great!
(audience applauding and laughing)
Look!
- Yes!
- Yes, yes, yes!
To everyone who said she
couldn't do it, she did it!
- Suck it!
Thank you!
- You're welcome.
I'm a great hype man.
- That's actually terrifying,
'cause I keep feeling
like it's gonna pop.
I've had a lot of balloons,
I throw a lot of parties
for my kids and they
always pop in my face.
You know I'm very proud of this number
so it's staying right there.
- I'm glad, I'm glad.
- Yep, worked hard for that.